Nach einer so hektischen Woche finde
ich endlich etwas Zeit, um dieses
unglaubliche und völlig unterschätzte
Modell unter die Lupe zu nehmen, von
dem meiner Meinung nach nicht genug
Leute wissen. Darf ich vorstellen:
MiniMax M 3.1 Flash Preview. Das
neueste Textmodell von MiniMax, das
offiziell auf MiniMax Code gestartet
ist. Und wenn man bedenkt, dass dies
ein Flash-Modell ist, muss ich sagen,
dass die Geschwindigkeit und Qualität
wirklich beeindruckend sind. Deshalb
mache ich jetzt ein eigenes Video
darüber. Was es noch interessanter
macht, ist, dass dies nicht einmal die
finale Version ist. Es befindet sich
derzeit in der Vorschau, was bedeutet,
dass MiniMax noch intensiv daran
arbeitet. Es besteht also eine gute
Chance, dass es von hier an noch besser
wird. MiniMax beschreibt M 3.1 Flash
als sein tägliches Arbeitstier-Modell,
das speziell für hochfrequente
Arbeitslasten entwickelt wurde und
gleichzeitig starke Fähigkeiten mit
Effizienz in Einklang bringt. Es ist
außerdem multimodal und richtet sich
an Entwickler, Fachleute und Kreative
in den Bereichen Programmierung,
Forschung, Analyse und kreative Arbeit.
MiniMax hat es speziell für die
tägliche Entwicklung positioniert:
schnell, zuverlässig und fähig, alles
von schnellen Fehlerbehebungen bis hin
zur Erstellung kompletter Funktionen zu
bewältigen. Ich bin ehrlich: Da es
sich noch um ein Vorschaumodell handelt
, wissen wir noch nicht alles darüber.
Wir kennen die vollständigen
Benchmark-Ergebnisse des Modells oder
die tieferen technischen Details, aus
denen M 3.1 Flash besteht, noch nicht.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass viele dieser
Informationen mit der offiziellen
Veröffentlichung des Modells bekannt
gegeben werden. Aber MiniMax bietet den
Leuten gerade eine ziemlich verrückte
Gelegenheit, es auszuprobieren, was ein
weiterer Grund ist, warum ich darüber
berichten wollte. Ursprünglich
kündigten sie zwei zeitlich begrenzte
Vorteile für MiniMax Code vom 28.
September bis zum 7. Oktober an, bei
denen Nutzer durch tägliche Logins
doppelte kostenlose Credits verdienen
konnten. Und MiniMax hat außerdem die
Token-Kontingente zurückgesetzt, als
MiniMax M 3.1 Flash Preview startete.
Aber dann gingen sie noch einen Schritt
weiter. Vor ein paar Tagen kündigte
MiniMax an, dass zur Feier des
chinesischen Nationalfeiertags MiniMax
M 3.1 Flash Preview für Abonnenten auf
MiniMax Code bis zum 7. Oktober
komplett kostenlos ist–ein echtes
Schnäppchen. Und laut MiniMax gibt es
keinen Credit-Verbrauch und keine
Limits. Wenn du also bereits Zugriff
auf MiniMax Code hast, ist das wirklich
ein Schnäppchen, denn du bekommst die
Möglichkeit, M 3.1 Flash Preview so
intensiv zu nutzen, wie du möchtest,
ohne dir Sorgen um deine Credits machen
zu müssen. Und genau das wollte ich
tun. Ich habe einige Zeit damit
verbracht, dieses Modell zu testen, um
zu sehen, wie sich Geschwindigkeit und
Qualität in realen Tests schlagen, und
habe seine Ergebnisse mit einigen der
viel größeren, derzeit verfügbaren
Modelle verglichen. Lassen Sie uns also
direkt in den Test einsteigen und sehen
, wie gut dieses Modell tatsächlich
ist. Aber sorry für die Unterbrechung,
Leute. Falls ihr es noch nicht getan
habt: Die Mehrheit von euch hat den
Kanal tatsächlich noch nicht abonniert
. Es würde mir also wirklich viel
bedeuten, wenn ihr dem Video ein Like
gebt oder einfach den Kanal abonniert,
da es mir sehr hilft, täglich Videos
für euch zu erstellen. Persönlich
habe ich ja schon erwähnt: Wenn ihr
den M-Code habt, erzielt ihr die besten
Ergebnisse mit diesem Modell, und genau
dafür nutze ich den Plus-Plan auch
für viele andere Dinge. Das ist also
einer der Hauptgründe, warum ich ihn
mit M-Code verwende. Ihr seht, dass ich
ihn auf maximale Schlussfolgerung
eingestellt habe, sogar mit nur 512K
Kontextfenster, aber man kann es auf 1
Million setzen, um es besser zu nutzen.
Seit ich es auf das Maximum eingestellt
habe, erziele ich unglaubliche
Ergebnisse, und es dauert gar nicht so
lange, diese Ausgaben zu erhalten,
obwohl ich angenommen hätte, dass es
Stunden dauern würde. Aber ihr könnt
dennoch sehen, dass man damit ziemlich
beeindruckende Ergebnisse erzielt. Eine
Sache, die man auch beachten sollte,
ist, dass ich 0%meines Kontingents
verbraucht habe. Das liegt daran, dass
dieses Modell für mich dank meines
Plans völlig kostenlos ist. Dieser
M-Code-Plan gewährt euch Zugriff
darauf. Das ist also einer der
Hauptgründe, warum ich es hervorheben
wollte. Falls ihr ihn nicht habt, ist
das auch völlig in Ordnung, da man ihn
meines Wissens nach auch im MiniMax
Cloud Chat komplett kostenlos nutzen
kann. Auf diese Weise erhaltet ihr
immer noch ein recht gutes Ratenlimit,
um kostenlos auf dieses Modell
zuzugreifen. Einer der größten
Mehrwerte dieses Modells ist seine
Geschwindigkeit und Effizienz. Dies ist
ein Flash-Modell, es ist also darauf
ausgelegt, unglaublich schnell zu sein.
Beeindruckend ist jedoch, dass es
dennoch qualitativ hochwertige
Ergebnisse liefern kann. Hier habe ich
den MiniMax-Code-Agenten selbst gebeten
, die M 3.1 Flash-Vorschau mit
maximaler Schlussfolgerung zu nutzen,
um ein ganzes Spiel im Call of Duty
Zombies-Stil von Grund auf zu erstellen
. Und die Ergebnisse sind unglaublich.
Es war nicht nur in der Lage, alles
extrem schnell zusammenzubauen, sondern
die Qualität ist regelrecht wahnsinnig
–ehrlich gesagt vergleichbar mit dem,
was ich von Opus gesehen habe. Lasst
uns das tatsächlich mal ansehen. Die
Qualität ist wirklich der Wahnsinn,
Leute. Das ist Runde Null, und hier
könnt ihr die Qualität der Texturen
und der 3 D-Umgebung sehen, die es
vollständig in 3GS aufbauen konnte.
Ihr habt verschiedene Räume, auf die
ihr zugreifen könnt. Es gibt
verschiedene Barrikaden. Es gibt sogar
Funktionen wie Pack-a-Punch, das sich
in diesem Raum befindet. Ich habe das
tatsächlich ein paar Mal gespielt,
weil es ziemlich viel Spaß gemacht hat
. Aber das hier ist einfach irre. Es
gibt sogar ein Kaufmenü, in dem man
verschiedene Dinge erwerben kann. Man
hat auch eine Lichtquelle. Man kann
sogar zwischen verschiedenen Waffen hin
-und herwechseln. Schauen wir uns das
mal an. Es wurde sogar ein toter Zombie
hinzugefügt, was ziemlich cool ist. Au
. Ich wurde schon ausgeschaltet. Das
ist unser erster Junge. Und wir können
sehen, dass alles so funktioniert wie
im Originalspiel. Man sieht, wie diese
Typen von draußen kommen. Sie können
die eigentliche Barrikade durchbrechen,
wie es dieser Kerl hier geschafft hat.
Wir können ihn ausschalten. Und dann
können wir diese anderen Typen
erledigen. Aber ich zeige euch noch ein
paar andere Dinge, denn ich habe sogar
mehrere Räume programmiert, was gut
ist. Also ist noch einer übrig. Lass
mich ihn mal suchen. Ich schalte mal
meine Taschenlampe ein. Ich weiß nicht
, ob wir hier rauskommen. Das ist der
Teil, der etwas abgefahren ist. Ich bin
außerhalb des Gebäudes. Man kann
nicht wirklich viel sehen. Aber
versuchen wir mal, diesen Kerl zu
finden. Wo bist du, Kumpel? Ich kann
ihn einfach nicht finden. Aber genau
davon spreche ich. Ja, Pack-a-Punch ist
hier. Man hält E gedrückt, kann es
kaufen und dann im Menü all die
anderen Dinge erwerben. Man kann auch
die Fenster reparieren. So kann man
sehen, wo sie sind. Um also
tatsächlich zu sehen, wo dieser Typ
ist. Einen Fehler kann man jedoch sehen
. Ich weiß nicht, warum es die Türen
blockiert. Das ist eine Sache. Aber es
ist für mich einfach verrückt, dass
dieses Modell so leistungsfähig ist
und eine solche Qualität liefern kann.
Ich sage nicht, dass es genau das ist,
was wir bei Opus gesehen haben, aber
die Gesamtqualität ist trotzdem
ziemlich gut. Es hat die meisten
Funktionen gut umgesetzt. Man hat die
tatsächliche Möglichkeit,
verschiedene Produkte zu kaufen, wie
zum Beispiel die verschiedenen Arten
von Waffen. Und dann gibt es die
Barrikaden, Zombies und natürlich
verschiedene Runden. Nun, ich weiß
nicht, wo dieser Typ steckt. Oh, da ist
er ja. Aber ja, ich zeige euch, dass
man sogar eine andere Waffe kaufen kann
, die ihre eigene Dynamik hat. Also
hast du die MPK, schau dir das mal an.
Man hat diesen Rückstoß. Man hat
diese Mündungsfeueranimation. Man
sieht sogar die Kugeln aus der Waffe
fliegen, was irgendwie der Wahnsinn ist
. Wenn man vor ein paar Jahren oder
Monaten gesagt hätte, dass das ein
Ergebnis eines Flash-Modells ist, wäre
man völlig aus dem Häuschen gewesen.
Und genau das sehen wir gerade. Es
sieht so aus, als ob jetzt Welle zwei
beginnt, also schauen wir mal, wie viel
Schaden wir bei dieser Welle hier
anrichten können. Okay, ich hänge
fest. Au, au, au, und ich bin gerade
gestorben. Wenn du die besten KI-Tools,
Workflows und Neuheiten vor allen
anderen willst, abonniere meinen
kostenlosen Newsletter über den Link
in der Beschreibung unten, der komplett
gratis ist. Jetzt ohne Scherz, das ist
eine Ausgabe von MiniMax M 3.1 Flash.
Das ist einfach unglaublich, weil ich
bisher noch kein Modell gesehen habe,
das diese Art von Detailgrad erzeugt.
Und hier hat es die Kopfhörer erstellt
. Es hat sogar ein Polster erstellt.
Der Detailgrad dieses Modells ist
einfach irre, vom eigentlichen
Farbschema bis hin zu den Texturen des
Metallbügels am Kopfhörer. Und nicht
nur das, Leute, es war natürlich auch
in der Lage, eine schöne Landingpage
dafür zu erstellen, was unglaublich
ist. Und ich zeige euch ein paar
Referenzbilder, die dabei waren. Es ist
ehrlich gesagt einfach verrückt, dass
es in der Lage war, diesen Detailgrad
mit dem Flash-Modell auszugeben. Es hat
zwar etwas länger gedauert, diese
Ausgabe mit Max Reasoning zu erhalten,
wo man die besten Ergebnisse bekommt.
Aber das ist etwas, von dem ich nie
erwartet hätte, dass ein Flash-Modell
es ausgeben könnte. Hier seht ihr
natürlich alle Details, wie die
vollständige Landingpage sowie ein
paar andere Dinge, die ihr auf der
ersten Seite gesehen habt. Hier ist
eine weitere solide
Frontend-Generierung dieses Modells,
aber diesmal hat es tatsächlich Scroll
World verwendet, ein Plugin innerhalb
des MiniMax-Agenten, das für
scrollgesteuerte Video-Websites
konzipiert ist. Hier wurde jedoch
verlangt, H3 zu verwenden, das
multimodale Videomodell von MiniMax,
und es wurde mit dem M 3.1 Flash von
MiniMax kombiniert, um die
Code-Interaktionen und Animationen zu
verarbeiten, damit sich alles
flüssiger und reaktionsschneller
anfühlt. Es ist einfach wahnsinnig,
dass es diese Assets verwendet hat und
diese spezifische Generierung dabei
herauskam. Hier ist unser berühmter
Nvidia-Landingpage-Prompt, bei dem wir
es anweisen, eine Landingpage für
Nvidias neueste Grafikkarte zu
erstellen. Und hier muss ich sagen,
dass es zwar schön, aber ein wenig
glanzlos ist. Normalerweise lassen wir
die meisten Modelle ein 3 D-Modell der
Grafikkarte erstellen, aber in diesem
Fall wurde nur ein 2 D-Modell generiert
. Es ist teilweise animiert. Die
Lüfter funktionieren, was natürlich
großartig ist. Und es wurde diese
Spiegelung hinzugefügt, was natürlich
ziemlich cool ist. Die Landingpage
bietet insgesamt viele tolle Effekte,
die Qualität der Front-End-Generierung
ist bei diesem speziellen Modell also
gut. Ich wollte eigentlich ein
spezifisches Ergebnis für die
Grafikkarte, aber abgesehen davon wirkt
die Landingpage ziemlich gelungen und
die Front-End-Qualität dieser
Generierungen ist wirklich gut. Das ist
eine wirklich schöne Landingpage, die
hier mit verschiedenen Typografien,
Bewegungen und Scroll-Triggern
zusammengestellt wurde. Man sieht bei
diesem Ergebnis, dass beim Scrollen
alles perfekt auf die Scroll-Trigger
abgestimmt ineinandergreift. Es wurden
verschiedene dynamische Bewegungen
sowie Texturen hinzugefügt, um das
Ganze lebendiger wirken zu lassen.
Alles wirkt sehr gut poliert, das ist
wirklich schön. Das sind kleine
qualitative Details, die man bei einem
Modell eigentlich nicht erwartet,
insgesamt also eine sehr solide
Generierung des M 3.1 Flash. Jetzt wird
es richtig interessant. Hier wurde das
MiniMax M 3.1 Flash mit maximalem
Reasoning gegen das GPT-6 Soul mit
maximalem Reasoning getestet. Die
Qualität ist einfach wahnsinnig. Die
Geschwindigkeit ist bei beiden Modellen
offensichtlich gut, da auch Soul recht
effizient ist, aber MiniMax war hier
sogar noch schneller fertig. Hier kann
man meiner Meinung nach sogar sagen,
dass es einen besseren Job gemacht hat
als das GPT-6-Modell. Das ist
natürlich Ansichtssache, aber beide
Ergebnisse sehen hervorragend aus, und
ich bin einfach erstaunt, dass das M
3.1 Flash solche Resultate liefern kann
. Bisher habe ich festgestellt, dass
dieses Modell weit über das Erwartete
hinausgeht. Auf dieser Landingpage habe
ich es angewiesen, eine SVG-Grafik zu
implementieren, und diese wurde
animiert, wobei viele Texturen
hinzugefügt wurden, um das SVG sehr
lebendig zu gestalten. Es sieht
wirklich aus wie ein Ergebnis von etwas
wie Sonic 5.5, aber es stammt
tatsächlich vom Flash-Modell. Und
denkt daran, Leute, all diese
Generierungen stammen vom
MiniMax-Client, der für mich momentan
komplett kostenlos ist, da ich den
Pro-Plan nutze. Und das ist ein
Detailgrad, den ich so nicht erwartet
hatte, da es nicht nur die SVG-Grafik
programmieren, sondern auch viele coole
Funktionen auf der Landingpage selbst
implementieren konnte, was das Ganze
deutlich aufwertet. Dies ist eine
Pagode, die als Voxel-Art generiert
wurde, und man kann hier die Qualität
erkennen. Hier hat es offensichtlich
die Atmosphäre und viele der Elemente
hinzugefügt, die wir in unseren
Modell-Releases sehen. Dass diese
Flash-Variante tatsächlich so etwas
ausgeben kann, ist wirklich
beeindruckend. Man kann die
Kirschblüten sehen, den See oder den
Teich und ein paar weitere Elemente,
die mit dieser spezifischen Ausgabe
generiert wurden. Ich bin also wirklich
begeistert von der Ausgabequalität
dieses speziellen Modells. Und hier ist
eine weitere Demo und ein Vergleich.
Die Anweisung war, eine
SVG-Illustration von Super Mario beim
Kaffeetrinken mit Peach zu erstellen,
und das ist es, was GPT-6 Pro generiert
hat. Offensichtlich ist es viel besser,
und der Detailgrad ist definitiv
wahnsinnig. Aber schauen Sie sich an,
was MiniMax M 3.1 Flash generiert hat.
Das ist ein Modell, das erstaunlich gut
mithält. Natürlich nicht auf
demselben Niveau, aber es generiert
eine ziemlich detaillierte und stimmige
Szene, besonders für ein Modell, das
stark auf Geschwindigkeit und Effizienz
ausgelegt ist. Ich sage nicht, dass es
GPT-6 Soul bei diesem einen Test direkt
schlägt, aber die Tatsache, dass ein
Flash-Modell so etwas produzieren kann,
ist wirklich wettbewerbsfähig und
beeindruckend. Es ist nun schon eine
Weile her, seit wir den Mac OS-Test
behandelt haben, und lassen Sie uns ihn
tatsächlich mit dem M 3.1 Flash
durchführen, da dies eine großartige
Möglichkeit ist, ein besseres
Verständnis dafür zu bekommen, wie
weit diese Modelle in Bezug auf
Leistung und Qualität gekommen sind.
Hier sieht es so aus, als hätte es
alle einzelnen Symbole in SVG
programmiert. Das einzige Problem, das
ich habe, ist, dass es nicht so
intuitiv ist wie das, was wir bei
anderen modernen Spitzenmodellen
gesehen haben, aber für eine
Flash-Variante immer noch ziemlich
ordentlich. Abgesehen davon scheint
alles andere interaktiv und
vollständig zu sein. Die obere Leiste
funktioniert wie sie soll. Sogar für
den Akku gibt es einen Energiesparmodus
, den man aktivieren kann, was ziemlich
cool ist. Sie haben WLAN, Sie haben die
Tonausgabe, mit der Sie herumspielen
können. Sie haben natürlich noch ein
paar andere Dinge, wie das
Benachrichtigungsfeld, das Sie öffnen
können. Aber jetzt lassen Sie uns
einen Blick auf ein paar andere Dinge
werfen. Sie können den Hintergrund
ändern, was schön ist. Sie haben die
Möglichkeit, die Akzentfarben zu
ändern, was tatsächlich funktioniert.
Und wenn man die Ergebnisse von so
etwas wie M 2.7 vergleicht, sieht man
eine drastische Veränderung in der
Qualität. Hier liefert das
Flash-Modell jetzt Ergebnisse wie
Sonnet oder Opus auf höchstem Niveau,
nur dass wir das jetzt bei der
Flash-Variante sehen. Du hast die
Möglichkeit, Spotlight zu öffnen. Ich
glaube, das kannst du sogar auch von
hier aus machen. All diese Apps
scheinen so zu funktionieren, wie sie
sollten, was ziemlich gut ist. Du hast
sogar eine Videocall-Funktion, glaube
ich. Ich glaube nicht, dass ich sie
öffnen kann. Oh, ja. Man kann
tatsächlich Leute anrufen und es gibt
diese Benachrichtigung. Du hast eine
echte Musik-App, die ziemlich gut
programmiert wurde und Musik abspielt,
was echt cool ist. Die Podcast-App, du
hast sogar den App Store. Wenn du etwas
kaufen oder darauf klicken willst,
lässt es dich das kaufen, was ziemlich
cool ist. Du hast Spiele, bei denen ich
nicht weiß, was das ist. Oh, es ist
Tic-Tac-Toe. Und du hast das Terminal,
den Taschenrechner und die
Aktivitätsanzeige, was ziemlich cool
ist. Und dann Freeform. Aber lass uns
mal einen Blick auf den Minecraft-Klon
werfen, den es generiert hat. Das ist
eigentlich ziemlich cool, weil es einen
Minecraft-Klon komplett in unseren
macOS-Klon integriert hat. Und das ist
irgendwie verrückt, weil dieses
Flash-Modell das ausgegeben hat, was
sogar besser ist als das, was wir bei
Gemini 3.8 gesehen haben. Du hast sogar
die Möglichkeit, Lichter zu platzieren
, was wir bei den anderen Varianten
noch gar nicht gesehen haben. Du hast
sogar diese Abbau-Animation, was
ziemlich cool ist. Du kannst
verschiedene Blöcke mit
unterschiedlichen Texturen platzieren.
Du kannst sogar verschiedene Dinge
herstellen, was nett ist. Das ist also
schon etwas, das wir bei anderen
Modellen so noch nicht wirklich gesehen
haben. Das ist also der Detailgrad, von
dem ich nie erwartet hätte, dass das
Flash-Modell ihn tatsächlich liefert.
Für einen weiteren Test wurde verlangt
, eine Insel im Voxel-Stil mit Palmen,
Hühnern, Hütten und einer Küste zu
bauen, alles innerhalb des
Minimax-Codes ohne externe Assets. Und
das war keine Einmal-Generierung, aber
nach ein paar Iterationen hat es den
Voxel-Stil perfekt getroffen. Es
enthielt alles, was gefordert wurde,
und fügte sogar von sich aus einige
zusätzliche Details hinzu, die die
Umgebung kompletter wirken ließen. Wir
kommen also an einen Punkt, an dem
diese Flash-Modelle tatsächlich diesen
Detailgrad liefern, den man eigentlich
von einer Pro-Variante erwarten würde.
Hier in 3 GS konnte es aus einer
einzigen Aufforderung heraus ein
komplettes 3 D-Dorfgelände erstellen.
Und ehrlich gesagt, das Verrückteste
ist, dass es nur 40 Minuten gedauert
hat, dies auszugeben, während es 0 $
gekostet hat. Und bedenken Sie, dies
ist immer noch das Vorschau-Modell.
Wenn MiniMax es vor der endgültigen
Veröffentlichung noch weiter
verbessern kann, stellen Sie sich vor,
wie beeindruckend das MiniMax 3.1 Flash
am Ende sein wird. Das Flash-Modell,
Leute, das ist etwas, das ich wirklich
immer wieder betonen möchte. Hier ist
nun ein weiterer Vergleich, bei dem die
M 3.1 Flash-Vorschau im Max-Modus gegen
Fable 5.1, aber mit mittlerem Reasoning
, antrat. MiniMax ist definitiv
unglaublich schnell, braucht etwa eine
Stunde und erreicht über 150 Token pro
Sekunde. Wogegen es bei Fable fast 2
Stunden dauerte, um diese Art von
Ausgabe zu erhalten. Nun, die
Gesamtqualität von MiniMax war nicht
ganz so stark, aber denken Sie daran,
dies ist ein Flash-Modell, und ich
denke, interessanter wäre der
Vergleich mit etwas wie GPT-6 Luna Max.
Und da kann man wahrscheinlich
vergleichbare Ergebnisse erzielen, aber
man sieht, dass Fable etwas
ausgefeilter ist als das M 3.1 Flash.
Aber ungeachtet dessen lieferte M 3.1
Flash ein ziemlich ordentliches
Ergebnis und das kostenlos. Es ist
definitiv mit Fable vergleichbar, da
die Ergebnisse wirklich gut aussehen.
Nur der Feinschliff ist nicht auf dem
gleichen Niveau wie bei den modernsten
Modellen. Aber wenn wir in Zukunft eine
Pro-Version für die 3.1-Serie von
MiniMax bekommen, wird das wirklich
alles in den Schatten stellen,
besonders wenn es diese Geschwindigkeit
beibehalten kann und gleichzeitig
offensichtlich näher an die Leistung
auf Grenz-Niveau heranreicht. Wenn
Ihnen dieses Video gefällt und Sie den
Kanal unterstützen möchten, können
Sie eine Spende über die Option „
Super Thanks“ unten in Betracht
ziehen. Oder Sie können unserem
privaten Discord beitreten, wo Sie
monatlich kostenlosen Zugriff auf
mehrere Abonnements verschiedener
KI-Tools sowie tägliche KI-Nachrichten
, exklusive Inhalte und vieles mehr
erhalten. Insgesamt ist meine Meinung
zur MiniMax M 3.1 Flash-Vorschau, dass
dies ein ernsthaft vielversprechendes
Modell ist, besonders wenn man sich
ansieht, wozu es in der Lage ist. Es
versucht nicht unbedingt, jedes
Spitzenmodell in Bezug auf die reine
Qualität zu schlagen. Seine größten
Stärken sind Geschwindigkeit,
Effizienz und dass es gut genug ist, um
eine riesige Menge an alltäglicher
Arbeit zu bewältigen, von
Programmierung, dem Testen
verschiedener Arten von Unit-Tests, 3
D-Umgebungen, Spielen, Websites,
einfach alles. Es ist etwas, das in
meinen persönlichen Tests beständig
solide Ergebnisse liefert, und es ist
ziemlich schnell. Und denken Sie daran,
dies ist nur die Vorschau. Minimax
arbeitet aktiv an der Weiterentwicklung
, daher wird es noch besser werden,
sobald sie das offizielle M 3.1 Flash
veröffentlichen, und ich werde
definitiv in Zukunft ein weiteres Video
dazu machen. Aber wenn ihr im Moment
Minimax M-Code habt, solltet ihr das
Beste daraus machen, denn dieses Modell
ist aktuell in diesem Plan kostenlos
enthalten. Also fordert das Modell
heraus, baut etwas Ambitioniertes und
seht, was es wirklich leisten kann,
denn ihr könnt derzeit experimentieren
, ohne euch Sorgen zu machen, eure
normalen Credits aufzubrauchen. Es
entstehen dabei keine zusätzlichen
Kosten, und es gibt absolut keine
Nachteile dabei. Ich werde auf jeden
Fall alle Links, die ich im heutigen
Video verwende, unten in die
Beschreibung setzen. Ihr könnt es
über die Cloud oder über M-Code
nutzen, was ihr auch lokal installieren
könnt. Aber mit diesem Gedanken, Leute
, vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen. Ein
großes Lob an Minimax für die
Entwicklung eines weiteren
unglaublichen Modells, das
offensichtlich sogar in der Flash-Stufe
überzeugt. Falls ihr es noch nicht
getan habt, werft unbedingt einen Blick
auf die World of AI School-Community.
Schaut euch den World of AI-Benchmark
und die Vibe-Coding-Plattform an.
Besucht unseren zweiten Kanal,
abonniert den Newsletter, kommt auf
unseren Discord und folgt mir auf
Twitter. Und zu guter Letzt: Abonniert
den Kanal, aktiviert die Glocke, gebt
dem Video einen Daumen nach oben und
schaut euch unsere früheren Videos an,
damit ihr bei den neuesten
KI-Nachrichten auf dem Laufenden bleibt
. Aber mit diesem Gedanken, Leute, habt
einen wunderbaren Tag. Verbreitet
Positivität und wir sehen uns schon
sehr bald wieder. Macht’s gut, Leute.